[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I'm working about
judicial independence
and how corruption
gets inside the system.
-It's been fascinating.
This research just tugs you in.
And you can't stop.
-For me, the project's
been a ton of fun.
Essentially just diving through
old historical newspapers
all day and seeing how they
thought about democracy,
about money, currency,
all these themes.
-I'm a journalist.
And I'm working
here at Radcliffe
on a book about psychedelics.
Teddy has been doing some really
indispensable work for me.
His idea of a good
time is to find
an archive were no other
undergraduate has ever been.
-In the chapter
about human dignity,
you mentioned that
there's Nussbaum's,
sort of their capabilities.
So we've met once a week.
My role has been to look at
other philosphers' writings
on the same sort of ideas,
and to help edit the book.
-If it's a genuine,
right, then it's
going to potentially, at least,
impose an obligation on me.
They were just a fantastic
sounding board for the work
that I was doing.
-In classes, we typically have
lectures of say, 300 people.
And then sections which are
often say, 10 people large.
And this has been an opportunity
to work with the professor
and to see something as big
as a book come together.
-My goal was sort of to
do a literature review.
I would read specific books
or specific parts of books,
summarize them,
sometimes translate them.
I would share with
him what I'd learned.
And he would see how that
connected to the research
that he'd done in the meantime.
It involved a lot of people
from different social classes.
-So in a way that was
a kind of reversal
of the traditional role
of professor and student.
And she was actually
teaching me.
And hopefully she was learning
something in the process
as well.
-And so sort of the idea
that even though there
are these new parties there,
the informal power structure of
[INAUDIBLE] was maintained.
-Mike and I talk
a lot about things
even beyond the project, things
like the state of journalism,
careers.
That's a salient concern.
I'm a junior.
I'm approaching senior year.
-Being able to encounter
just really brilliant minds
and to be able to see
them work at a close range
and to collaborate on a
project is exactly almost
in its entirety what I want
to do as an undergraduate.
It's also meant just
financial stability
for me, which has
been very useful.
-Having Tianna as
like a real world
professional creative
writer, and being
able to enter in
conversation with her
with other students has
been like an experience I
don't think is paralleled
anywhere else on campus.
-Every week you got
to go to a place
and feel intellectually
awakened by the conversations
that you were having.
-One of the gifts
of the Radcliffe
has been able to work
with my partners truly
as partners, and
not as students.
And so we've been in
the work together.
That's been phenomenal.
-Yeah.
-I think we're all--
-We're all trying to say that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]